die pole umkehr von nord- und südpol
steht wohl an und das wird weitreichende
folgen haben die letzte pole für einige
jahrhunderte geschafft vor rund 40.000
jahren und selbst die hatte
weitreichende folgen für das leben auf
der erde wie wahrscheinlich ist eine
polo in der nahen zukunft und mit
welchen folgen müssen wir also jetzt
rechnen klicks um seine user hier gibt
es drei mal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen das
erdmagnetfeld ist ein super wichtiges
schutzschild für das leben auf der erde
denn es schützt uns vor der harten
kosmischen strahlung aus dem weltall und
sorgt dafür dass gefährliche sonnenwinde
abgelenkt werden diese geladenen
teilchen ströme werden von der sonne in
alle richtungen ausgestoßen
diese hoch energetischen teilchen
stellen eine riesige gefahr für unsere
infrastruktur dar denn sie können nicht
nur unsere stromnetze sondern aus
satelliten beschädigen oder gar komplett
zerstören
doch die fachwelt weiß schon seit
längerer zeit dass das erdmagnetfeld
sich verändert es hat sich im laufe der
zeit sogar schon mehrmals komplett
umgepolt heißt also im klartext das
erdmagnetfeld ist nicht immer gleich
intensiv im laufe der zeit kam es immer
mal wieder zu phasen in denen ich
schwächelte teilweise kam es sogar zu
einer kompletten umpolung des
erdmagnetfeldes wo beispielsweise vor
780.000 jahren der magnetische nordpol
wurde hier also zum südpol und umgekehrt
bei manchen diese ereignisse dies eine
solche umpolung sogar über jahrmillionen
jahre an doch das ist nicht immer der
fall
mehr war fanden außerdem auch kürzere
sprünge stadt die fachleute auch als
sogenannte exkursionen bezeichnen
nach einigen hundert jahren springt das
magnetfeld dabei wieder in seine alte
produkt zurück was bedeutet solch ein
ereignis für das leben auf der erde gab
es anzeichen im vorfeld dass eine
umpolung bevorstehen und wie
wahrscheinlich ist eine umpolung in der
nahen zukunft antworten auf all diese
fragen gibt es in diesem video
forschungsteams weltweit sind sich
jedenfalls im risiko einer umpolung
bewusst und versuchen unter anderem die
zeitliche verläufe einer solchen
umpolung zu verstehen denn trotz
intensiver forschung sind die
geometrische struktur das timing und die
dauer der pole
noch immer nicht im detail verstanden
ein australisches forschungsteam hat
sich eine magnetische exkursion jetzt
genauer angeschaut die rund 42.000 jahre
zurückliegt die magnetfeldstärke war
hier auf rund 28 prozent ihres
ursprünglichen wertes abgesunken und die
umpolung dauerte rund 800 jahre die
fachleute interessierte vor allem wann
genau dieses ereignis stattfand wie
lange es dauert und welche folgen diese
umpolung für das leben auf der erde
hatte dazu untersuchten sie ganz
besondere zeit sollten die sogenannten
carry bäume in einem sumpf in neuseeland
denn diese war tatsächlich in dieser
zeit der pol umkehr gewachsen und wurden
durch den sumpfigen grund dann
konserviert und das muss man sich mal
vorstellen einer dieser fossilien bäume
war 1700 jahre alt geworden ein großes
glück für die fachleute denn das gewebe
eines solchen baumes kann somit hinweise
auf die zeit des sogenannten laut schaub
ereignisses geben
die rede ist von isotopen zeugnissen und
genauer gesagt ging es dem
forschungsteam um den gehalt des isotops
kohlenstoff-14 in den jahresringen des
baumes durch diese analyse gelang es den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern also auf die zeit der
umpolung zurückzublicken
denn wenn das magnetfeld der erde
schwächelt führt die kosmische strahlung
dazu dass stickstoffatome zu kohlenstoff
zerschlagen werden so wird dann also
vermehrt von den kohlenstoff 14 isotop
in der erdatmosphäre gebildet und
tatsächlich führte diese analyse zu
einem interessanten ergebnis dazu chris
turner der an der aktuellen studie
beteiligt war
zum ersten mal können wir den zeitpunkt
und die auswirkungen der letzten
umpolung des erdmagnetfeldes präzise
bestimmen
den untersuchungen zufolge hatte sich
bereits in der zeit von vor rund 42.300
50 jahren eine enorme zunahme der c14
werte in der erdatmosphäre zugetragen
die umpolung selbst fand dann vor 41.500
jahren statt wie das forschungsteam in
der aktuellen studie schreibt heißt also
das erdmagnetfeld muss schon im vorfeld
der umpolung extrem an intensität
verloren haben dazu chris turner selbst
während dieses adams ereignisses fiel
die feldstärke das erdmagnetfeld ist auf
nur noch 0 bis 6 prozent im prinzip
hatten wir zu dieser zeit gar kein
magnetfeld mehr unser schutzschirm gegen
zwischen strahlung war komplett weg und
das gibt natürlich nicht ohne folgen für
das leben auf der erde tatsächlich
zeigen die analysen des australischen
forschungsteams dass sowohl das erdklima
als auch die umweltbedingungen
erheblichen veränderungen unterworfen
waren es kam zu einem regelrechten
bombardement kosmischer strahlung
dies führte zu einer sogenannten
ionisierung der atmosphäre die
sauerstoff moleküle in der erdatmosphäre
wurden auseinandergerissen und die
elektronen abgetrennt licht emissionen
wurden dadurch verursacht und genau
dieser prozess wird unter fachleuten als
ionisierung beschrieben es kam zu einer
verdünnung der schützenden ozonschicht
die teilchen die bei diesen prozessen
entstanden führten dann in verbindung
mit dem geschwächten magnetfeld so
polarlichter über dem ganzen globus da
die atmosphäre in diesem zeitraum sehr
stark elektrisch aufgeladen war kam es
zu krassen leucht phänomenen wie
beispielsweise blitzen
dazu schreibt das forschungsteam die
ungefilterte strahlung aus dem weltraum
riss die sauerstoffmoleküle in der
erdatmosphäre auseinander trend der
elektronen ab und verursachte
lichtemissionen die frühen menschen
müssen eine unglaubliche aurora gesehen
haben leuchtende schleier und schlieren
am gesamten himmel
den menschen muss es vorgekommen sein
wie das ende der welt für diese
untersuchung waren die koreaner den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern sehr hilfreich das
überraschte sogar das forschungsteam
selbst diese kaum räume sind wie der
rosetta stein sie helfen und zeugnisse
von umweltveränderungen ausfüllen
eisbohrkernen und torf morgen rund um
die welt zusammenzubringen die
modellsimulationen offenbarten außerdem
auch noch dass sich durch diese vorgänge
in der atmosphäre auch das klima
veränderte so führte der einstrom
ultravioletter strahlung dazu dass das
klima in den gemäßigten breiten der
südhalbkugel kühler und trockener wurde
so auch in australien die gletscher auf
der nordhalbkugel rückten dem
forschungsteam zufolge fordert so heißt
es dass adams ereignis scheint einen
bedeutenden klimatischen ökologischen
und archäologischen umbruch zu
repräsentieren
der bislang weitgehend unerkannt
geblieben
die forschenden vermuten sogar dass
diese veränderung auch einfluss auf die
entwicklung der tierwelt und der
menschheit gehabt haben könnten denn zu
dieser zeit getan einige gravierende
dinge beispielsweise starben in europa
die neandertaler aus und in australien
die mega fauna
zudem wissen wir dass zu dieser zeit die
menschen in südost asien und europa
vermehrt höhen aufsuchten und deren
felswände bemalten dazu heißt es in der
studie
insgesamt decken diese erhalten ist
wichtige fragen über die evolutionären
auswirkungen von geomagnetischen
umpolung und exkursionen im laufe der
erdgeschichte
die große frage wie wahrscheinlich ist
es dass in nächster zeit eine umpolung
des erdmagnetfeldes ansteht da die
forschungsteams weltweit wissen dass das
magnetfeld alles andere als stabil ist
suchen sie intensiv nach anzeichen die
auf eine weitere erholung hinweisen
könnten als indizien für eine erneute um
pol und geht beispielsweise die
deutliche abschwächung des magnetfeldes
als ein weiterer hinweis wird auch die
erkenntnis gedeutet dass der magnetische
nordpol derzeit schneller wandert als
man erwartet hatte
doch die fachleute selbst sind sich
nicht einig wie genau diese symptome
interpretiert werden sollten handelt es
sich also nur um eine schwächephase die
wieder vorbeigeht oder handelt es sich
tatsächlich um vorboten die auf eine pol
umkehr hindeuten durchschnittlich
gesehen findet eine umpolung alle
500.000 jahre statt die großen offenen
fragen dazu gibt es im vorfeld überhaupt
anzeichen oder verläuft eine umpolung
sehr schnell studien die bisher zu
diesem thema veröffentlicht wurden
kommen zu unterschiedlichen ergebnissen
eine studie aus dem jahr 2014 geht
beispielsweise davon aus dass die
jüngste umpolung sehr sehr schnell
abgelaufen sein muss und zwar innerhalb
von nur 100 jahren eine hypothese die
manchen fachleuten den schlaf raubt ihm
zeit für warnungen oder anpassungen
liebe unter diesen umständen kaum
es gibt aber auch andere studien nach
denen solch eine umpolung jahrtausende
dauert wie lange dauert dieser prozess
also tatsächlich genau dieser
entscheidenden frage ist der forscher
brett singer vor zwei jahren 2009/10
zusammen mit seinem team nachgegangen
dafür wurden
demand und eisbohrkerne analysiert die
von vulkanausbrüchen stammen die vor
etwa 700 bis 800 1000 jahren
stattgefunden haben die fachleute können
unter anderem durch die ausrichtung
eisenhaltiger mineralien erstarrter lava
eine solche pohl und kehre konstruieren
dazu bretzinger lavaströme sind ideale
zeit zeugen für das magnetfeld denn sie
enthalten viele eisenhaltige mineral und
wenn diese erkalten konservieren sie
richtung und stärke des gerade
herrschenden magnetfeldes der analyse
offenbarte etwas überraschendes demnach
dauerte eine pol umkehr wohl deutlich
länger als man bisher angenommen hatte
konkret konnten die forschenden die
jüngste pohl & care ins visier nehmen
die vor rund 780.000 jahren
stattgefunden hatte also diese die dann
länger gehalten hat und diese hat laut
der aktuellen studie achtung mindestens
22.000 jahre lang gedauert 18.000
jahrelang erfolgt obwohl zunächst eine
phase der instabilität daraufhin folgte
der wechsel der etwa 4000 jahre dauerte
die pol umkehr dauerte demnach doppelt
so lang wie es bisherige studien
errechnet hatten damals hat sich das
magnetfeld wohl zunächst mehrmals
drastisch abgeschwächt bevor sich seine
pole dann verschoben haben und sich dann
komplett umgekehrt hatten somit verläuft
eine umpolung des erdmagnetfeldes also
deutlich langsamer als gedacht denn noch
ist weiter offen ob in der nahen zukunft
mit einer pool umkehr rechnen müssen
eine verlässliche vorhersage lässt sich
dazu einfach nicht treffen wir müssen
uns einfach daran gewöhnen
wir sind auf der erde gefahren
ausgesetzt super vulkane oder asteroiden
drohen uns ja auch extraterrestrische
staub schwämme eiszeit auf der erde
durch katastrophale asteroiden crash
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
zwar diesen galactic science and future
nur dann verpasst er nichts bis dann
bleib dran